hey Lauren hey Brian did you know that
my sister's husband's mother's uncle was
married to your great-grandmother wait
how did you figure that out does that
mean we're related well I loaded our
family trees onto Janis graph running on
Google Cloud BigTable ran some queries
and found out no I'm just kidding with
you but I can tell you some pretty
interesting things about the Greek gods
let's check it out
Janice Graf is an open source
distributed graph database amongst as
many different features one of the key
strengths of Janice graph is the idea of
pluggable storage you can use various
storage back-end technologies such as
Apache Cassandra HBase or in our case
we're going to use Google Cloud BigTable
so let's go ahead and create a BigTable
cluster we're going to call this Janice
graph and as you can see here there are
a number of different options that you
can configure let's set up a production
instance to show what this looks like
we're going to choose solid state disk
since we are just testing this and want
to run it quickly we're also going to
deploy this in u.s. central one in the F
zone set it for the minimum production
size of three notes for a cluster and
away we go
now that our cluster is deployed we're
going to use our cloud shell to deploy
Janice graph itself which we're going to
deploy onto a google kubernetes engine
cluster that we have also created in
advance for this we will use helm to set
this up while this is deploying let's
take a look at the sample graph that we
are going to use for the demonstration
and see what that looks like here is the
sample graph data that we will be using
for this demonstration the sample
dataset is both in the Google cloud
tutorial and is also available on the
Janice graph tutorial the graph of the
gods-- outlines the relationships
between various ancient Greek gods their
pets the monsters they battled and also
where they lived different entities that
you see here with attributes are
referred to as ver Texas and the
relationships between those vertexes are
called edges so for example in the lower
left side of this graph we can see that
at the start other vertex labelled
Hercules there is an edge protruding
from that on the right which that shows
that he has battled a monster named
Cerberus what this enables us to do is
query the relationships between
different entities when storing this
kind of information in a regular
relational database it typically
requires complex joints to manage
especially so on the level of joining
gets multiple layers
deep with graph traversal languages this
makes it far more intuitive and easier
to query these different relationships
this also requires a new language to
query it and in Janice graph we call
this language gremlin to start off with
let's just run a simple command to find
the name of Jupiter's brother in a
relational database you would perform a
query across two tables here we see that
this command is starting from a vertex
denoted G dot V that has the name
Jupiter and we are looking for outward
relationships of type brother and want
the values of those names Neptune and
Pluto is what comes back which matches
with what's on the graph on the right
now let's look at the edges themselves
instead of just looking up where Pluto
lives we now want to see Y which is an
attribute of an edge so the query here
also starts at Pluto but now we're
looking for an outward edge denoting
where he lives and we want to look at
the reason in a typical relational
database this would always involve some
sort of gods table a location table and
most likely some form of a
cross-reference table between the two
you can start to see how graph traversal
makes these kinds of operations far
easier lastly let's look at a query with
yet another join here we want to see a
third level relationship from Jupiter in
this case we want to see where Jupiter's
brothers dog lives if we see here the
query simply just starts at Jupiter
looks for the next level relationship
marks brother then looks for his pet and
finally returns where he lives if we see
the results here is marked as a Tartarus
which corresponds also to the visual
representation of the graph on the right
so there you have a few quick examples
of graph traversal and what's really
cool about this particular architecture
is that because it is backed by Google
Cloud BigTable as a storage mechanism we
know that this architecture will allow
this to scale as
as the graph is going to grow so now
you've seen that by using Janus graph on
Google cloud platform you can make some
pretty useful connections in the data
that you wouldn't normally be able to
make in a transactional sequel database
and also if you want to run this
tutorial for yourself be sure to check
out the link below if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like comment and
subscribe for more great Google cloud
platform content thanks for watching
[Music]